- Fermer toutes les écoles,
cégeps, universités et services
de garde. On a la responsabilité
de le faire.
- Notre emphase va être sur
comment aider les Canadiens
dans ce moment difficile.
- Aujourd'hui, le conseil
est de reporter ou d'annuler
tout voyage non essentiel.
- Le gouvernement du Canada
relances fiscales importantes.
- On ne prévoit aucune pénurie
de nourriture.
- Je vais avoir deux lubies
dans cette période c'est aplanir
la courbe puis lavez-vous
les mains.
- Je réalise très bien que
je vous en demande beaucoup.
Bonsoir à tous, bienvenue
à l'émission.
Les mesures et l'ampleur
frappent l'imaginaire,
Imaginez, le plus haut cercle
du pouvoir doit considérer
la possibilité que Justin
Trudeau soit malade
et toutes les conséquences.
On doit aussi s'adapter, c'est
une nouvelle vie qui s'annonce,
collectivement. Au cours de
cette émission les experts
répondront à vos questions sur
l'isolement volontaire,
notamment, les marchés du
travail, les droits et les
responsabilités, vous avez été
inondé de questions et on va
revenir sur les risques
notamment Julie Émond et avec
moi pour recevoir les questions
des téléspectateurs.
- Oui, vous avez toutes sortes
de questions, de réactions,
commentaires face à ce sujet qui
fait couler énormément donc
voici les moyens pour nous
contacter. Par courriel avec
l'adresse habituelle et nous
sommes en diffusion simultanée
sur Facebook live.
Et bien sûr en va diriger les
questions à nos experts.
- Je vous présente mes invités,
Cécile Tremblay, Pascal
Bouillon, on sent qu'il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétude dans la
société à ce moment et Diane
Francoeur médecins spécialistes
du Québec. Le système de santé
doit travailler à son meilleur,
et Adrienne Saint Arnaud en va
aborder avec vous les nouvelles
du jour, à Québec notre chef de
bureau Sébastien Bovet, et
Madeleine Blais Morin à Ottawa.
Je vais commencer avec
Sébastien.
- Bonjour.
- La fermeture des garderies et
de toutes les écoles du primaire
à l'université, on s'y attendait
un petit peu mais le dosage,
pour arriver à valider tout ça.
- Il y a eu une grande gradation
au cours de la semaine.
Rappelez-vous que Monsieur
Legault était inquiet et ne
voulait pas prendre de mesures
et on se retrouve quatre jours
plus tard avec les écoles
primaires, secondaires, fermés.
Hier le directeur de la santé
publique esquivait un peu la
fermeture des écoles en disant
qu'on en était pas là. Qu'est-ce
qui a changé dans les 24 heures?
L'Ontario a décidé de fermer ses
écoles pour trois semaines,, les
interdictions de rassemblement,
il y a un équilibre entre les
aspects santé publique de dire
qu'il faut garder des gens qui
sont peut-être allés en voyage
pendant la semaine de relâche et
qui pourrait être un vecteur de
propagation de maladies et
l'aspect politique ou si on veut
rassurer les gens.
- Madeleine, du côté d'Ottawa
aussi, de nouvelles consignes de
restriction et...
- là aussi on veut trouver un
équilibre parce qu'il y avait de
la pression pour qu'on puisse
contrôler davantage les entrées
aux frontières. Le gouvernement
décide de limiter le nombre de
repas ou de avions
internationaux devront se poser
pour concentrer les agents de
placer en quarantaine volontaire
et pour les voyageurs qui
viennent d'Iran ou d'Italie de
se placer en quarantaine
obligatoire pour une période de
14 jours, aussi des mesures
annoncées pour des bateaux de
croisière, ceux qui ont plus de
500 passagers ne pourront
accoster et on réfléchit à la
possibilité d'ajouter certains
contrôles comme limiter certains
vols en fonction de leur pays
d'origine. Cette décision n'est
pas prise est vraiment le
gouvernement semble se garder la
porte ouverte pour avoir des
mesures de contrôle encore plus
sévère.
- En a pas encore répondu au
Canada de façon claire et nette
pour ce qui est de fermer les
frontières à l'Europe alors je
vais tout de suite parler à
Andréeanne des mesures
économiques.
- Ça fait plusieurs jours que
les milieux économiques
réclament des mesures et en a eu
droit important du côté
d'Ottawa. Conférence de presse
conjointe entre le ministre des
Finances et le gouvernement de
la Du Canada. On a annoncé une
autre baisse du taux directeur,
une deuxième à moins de deux
semaines, encore une fois d'un
demi-point. Ça veut dire que les
coûts d'emprunt pour les
particuliers, tout ça va
baisser, on veut donner aux
Canadiens et aux entreprises
plus de facilité à avoir un
coussin financier et la Banque
du Canada n'a pas exclu l'idée
de baisser encore. Le
gouvernement est toujours en
train de préparer son grand plan
d'aide avec des mesures fiscales
qui viendront vraisemblablement
la semaine prochaine mais on a
quand même annoncé de mesures
aujourd'hui, d'une part en
consentant des baisses et le
surintendant des institutions
financières annoncées que en va
abaisser le réseau de stabilité
financière donc elle rendant
leur coffre à moins d'argent, ça
libère 300 milliards de dollars
qu'ils veulent consentir un
prêt, on veut faire souffler un
peu l'économie.
- En va en parler avec le
conseil du patronat mais
Sébastien et Madeleine vous
incarnait les porte-parole de
capitale alors que les premiers
ministres ne sont pas sur la
même longueur d'onde quant à la
sécurité des citoyens mais il
n'y a pas d'animosité. Du côté
de Québec, on veut rassurer les
citoyens, les entreprises et les
travailleurs.
- Petite déception exprimée en
coulisses après le point de
presse de Justin Trudeau, ça
manquait de fermeté concernant
les voyageurs étrangers. On
aurait souhaité des mesures plus
ferme. On a dénoncé l'espèce
d'incohérence des dernières
heures ou les Québécois qui
revenaient au pays, de voyageurs
étrangers pouvaient se promener
mais pour certains pays
uniquement. Monsieur Legault a
répondu que d'autres pays soient
visés par ce resserrement de
voyageurs étrangers. On a été un
peu choqué de savoir qu'il y
avait encore des avions de Chine
qui atterrissait à Montréal. Le
gouvernement veut rassurer, il
prend des mesures extrêmes pour
dire que nous sommes en contrôle
de la situation et on sait que
ça va chambouler de vie mais on
essaie de faire en sorte que ça
chamboule le moins possible. On
va avoir des services de
première ligne avec les
infirmières et les médecins,
pour les gens qui doivent rester
à la maison X en travailleur
autonome, il y a des
compensations et on demande aux
employeurs d'être plus
compréhensif.
- 14 jours de fermeture ou une
durée indéfinie?
- 14 jours à réévaluer.
Madeleine, tout à l'heure le
président Donald Trump a reconnu
avoir parlé avec le premier
ministre Trudeau mais il a dit
qu'il n'avait pas parlé de
frontières. C'est étonnant.
- Il y a eu tout un effort de
lobbying au lendemain de
l'annonce du président américain
qu'il allait empêcher les
voyageurs européens de rentrer
aux États-Unis parce qu'on ne
voulait pas fermer la frontière
terrestre entre le Canada et les
États-Unis. Du côté canadien en
a insisté sur l'importance de
cette frontière, 400 000
personnes par jour la traverse
et il est essentiel pour la
santé économique du pays. En
voulait s'assurer que cette
frontière allait demeurer
ouverte surtout qu'on n'avait
pas été prévenu du côté canadien
que le président américain
s'apprêtait à empêcher les
voyageurs européens de venir aux
États-Unis. On n'a pas senti du
côté canadien qu'il y avait de
la pression de la part de
l'administration américaine pour
qu'il y ait fermeture ou qu'on
limite.
- Je continue avec vous
Madeleine, c'est quand même une
nouvelle importante, notre
premier ministre en isolement
volontaire parce que son époux
est atteinte du coronavirus
après un voyage au royaume uni.
Il a fait le point sur son état
de santé et sa nouvelle vie en
quarantaine. Est-ce qu'il va
être capable de faire face à la
crise?
- C'est pour ça qu'il y a eu le
point de presse devant sa
résidence officielle. Il voulait
démontrer qu'il était capable de
travailler et il a dit qu'il ne
présentait aucun symptôme. Il a
expliqué que selon les avis
reçus des médecins et des
experts de la santé publique,
c'est pas nécessaire de subir un
test parce que le test serait
non concluant. C'est un test
pour quand il y'a des symptômes
et il dit qu'il n'en a pas. Il
peut continuer de faire son
travail sans être testé et il
dit que si jamais il présente
des symptômes il subirait le
test mais pour le moment, il
déclare qu'il n'est pas atteint
et qu'il peut continuer à faire
des appels. Il a parlé au
premier ministre britannique, au
premier ministre italien,
Emmanuel Macron et il a parlé au
premier ministre provinciaux
mais c'est quand même un
inconvénient. Il ne peut avoir
des contacts en personne.
- Et avoir un G7 d'urgence par
vidéoconférence autrement mais
on a su que ses enfants avaient
joué au Lego.
- C'est pas la seule mesure
exceptionnelle. Il y a eu cette
suspension des travaux à la
chambre des Communes, première
fois depuis Santa.
- Vous restez au boulot, vous
n'êtes pas encore en
télétravail. Il y avait des
marchés aujourd'hui et il se
sent ressaisi un peu.
- Ça a été pénible, il y a
encore eu une semaine en
montagnes russes. Vous pouvez
dire de la semaine qui se
termine que ça été le pire
encore une fois. On a eu un
rebond, au fur et à mesure du
discours de Donald Trump, sur
l'argent débloqué pour venir en
aide aux Américains, ça été la
meilleure journée en bourse
aujourd'hui depuis 2008. Mais
c'est en contrepartie, ça
faisait suite à une dépit
entrant en si on fait le bilan
de la semaine, ça été une
semaine douloureuse, de perte de
huit à 12 % pour les principaux
indices et tous les signaux
montrent que c'est loin d'être
terminé.
- Sébastien, point de presse du
premier ministre demain à 13
heures.
- Ça va tre un exercice
quotidien.
- Et à Ottawa?
- On s'attend à avoir des points
de presse idéalement en semaine
mais on pense aussi à la santé
et à la forme de docteurs qui
sont le, en veut s'assurer que
le monde ne s'épuise pas.
- Pour contrer l'inquiétude,
merci à vous trois.
DANIELLE MCCANN, ministre
de la Santé du Québec
- Mais à partir de la semaine
prochaine, il y a des médecins,
au Québec, que ce soit
dans les hôpitaux ou dans
les cliniques médicales,
qui vont pouvoir donner des
services par téléconsultation.
Je veux vous dire également
qu'en lien avec le dépistage,
on déploie, au Québec, une
douzaine de cliniques de plus!
- Je reçois sur le plateau Diane
Francoeur, bonsoir Docteur, ça
visait davantage des
omnipraticiens qui peuvent faire
de la télémédecine.
- Nous aussi, j'ai testé le
produit cet après-midi. En le
testé au bureau, en attester la
plate-forme, on a envoyé nos
employés et on a fait prendre
des photos, c'est vraiment une
excellente nouvelle, ça fait
plusieurs semaines qu'on
demandait au ministère de ne
trouver une plate-forme parce
que vous savez, à chaque jour on
change de direction par
précaution. On a pris des
mesures importantes et c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire. On a annulé
des rendez-vous électifs,
certaines chirurgies la semaine
prochaine parce qu'on n'est pas
encore certain d'avoir accès à
la plate-forme, aussitôt qu'elle
va être déployée et
fonctionnelle on va essayer de
voir nos patients à risque, nos
grands malades, le produit
fonctionne bien.
- Ce qui est intéressant là-
dedans, on en avait peut-être
pas assez parlé depuis un mois
compare du coronavirus, on parle
de prévention et de précaution,
on oublie peut-être les patients
qui font en sorte que le système
est déjà à pleine capacité. À
savoir est-ce qu'on guérit untel
ou Intel, qu'on soit obligé de
faire un choix déchirant.
- C'est pour ça qu'on s'est
entendu avec l'équipe
ministérielle, on passe beaucoup
d'art pour essayer de trouver
les problèmes et les solutions.
On s'entend qu'il y a certaines
personnes âgées ou pas
confortables avec les
ordinateurs, il y a toujours le
vieux téléphone et les médecins
auront la permission de soigner
les patients à distance.
- Temporaire?, Souhaitez-vous
que ce soit une mesure qui dure
longtemps?
- C'est sûr qu'on va l'instaurer
davantage par la suite. En tout
premier lieu il faut décider
quelle est la valeur ajoutée
pour le patient. Elle comprend
le risque de le contaminer ou de
se priver de certains outils
essentiels. Mais maintenant
qu'on a la plate-forme, on
pourra ajouter des joujoux
dedans.
- Ça va désengorger les
urgences.
- Avec cette crise, je pense
qu'on va changer nos façons de
faire et on n'en sortira tous
grandis mais pour l'instant,
c'est arrivé aujourd'hui, c'est
la bonne nouvelle.
- Et la RAMQ...
- on s'échelonnera avec eux
après mais moi mon rôle c'était
de s'assurer qu'on donne les
services.
- Vous êtes pas le porte-parole
de tous le système de santé,
il y a plusieurs disciplines,
est-ce que le climat qui règne,
quels sont les échos que vous
avez quant à l'inquiétude?
- Il faudra mari invité demain,
je vais passer la nuit à
l'hôpital, je pense que le
personnel est un peu inquiet
mais il faut rassurer les gens.
Pour l'instant c'est pas facile,
la crise est là, il faut prendre
des décisions rapides mais pour
l'instant, il n'y a pas de
patients en péril. On est
capable de s'occuper des gens
qui sont très malades. On sait
qu'il y a un problème avec le
811, je demande au médecin en
quarantaine de répondre au
téléphone, et en a une de nos
membres, microbiologiste très
présente qui a appliqué et qui
fait du téléphone.
- On va lui parler tout à
l'heure, elle est un isolement
volontaire, pour qu'elle nous
explique bien les consignes et
les contraintes, en s'inspirant
du couple Trudeau, parce que
Madame Sophie Grégoire elle-même
est atteinte. Merci.
Je voudrais dire que le Docteur
Alain Poirier directeur de la
Santé publique pour la région de
l'Estrie s'est joint à nous.
Je vais peut-être avoir des
réactions de ce qu'on entend sur
les mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui.
- Je pense que les mesures
étaient nécessaires, va dans la
bonne direction, on en fait
assez mais toujours approprié
par la situation actuelle. C'est
sûr que si on voit que la
transmission se met à se faire
dans la communauté, il va
falloir hausser encore plus les
mesures mais c'est bien avec une
mesure à la fois, ça permet à la
société de s'adapter. Vous
n'avez pas idée de combien de
mémos nous avons reçu à
l'hôpital toute la journée et on
nous envoie des directives
auquel tout le monde doit
s'adapter. Je pense qu'en fait
un bon travail mais c'est quand
même assez lourd.
- Madame Brion, qu'est-ce qui
vous frappe le plus, parce que
quand on vous a invité pour
parler des angoisses.
- Il y a une certaine fébrilité
et je pense que la question se
pose sur comment on peut
maximiser la résilience sociale
des Québécois pour traverser
cette épreuve le mieux possible.
- Dr Poirier est en ligne?
- Je suis là.
- Vous sortez tout juste d'un
point de presse régionale, vous
avez manqué le début mais on a
beaucoup décrit les mesures
annoncées par Québec. Est-ce que
Québec est allé aussi loin qu'il
doit aller dans les
- Il y a des considérations très
particulières. On a cette
opportunité de voir ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs avant ici. Ce que
veut éviter, c'est l'éclosion en
Europe, notamment en Italie que
les experts ont observée et ils
ont dit on ne veut pas ça. On
prend des mesures qui ont l'ère
un peu un peu forte. Comme il y
a eu la semaine de relâche, ce
sont des mesurant milieu
scolaire, les avions... il y a e
escalade des mesures alors que
les gens voient tellement encore
la maladie.
- On a perdu Docteur Poirier. La
question que je posais au
Docteur Poirier, c'est la
suivante : est-ce qu'on est allé
aussi loin qu'on doit aller?
- La question des frontières,
c'est certain qu'il y a des
choses à améliorer encore. La
discordance entre les Canadiens
qui reviennent les voyageurs
étrangers ne fait aucun sens
logique alors il faut régler ça.
Et l'information qui est donnée
à l'aéroport, aux gens qui
reviennent de voyage.
- C'est encore trop flou. Julie
et moi, on entend toutes sortes
de thermes dans les mesures qui
sont annoncées. Il est important
de distinguer les mots ouais
isolement, distanciation.
- Il se pose plusieurs
questions, mais avec tous ces
temps qu'on utilise à toutes les
sauces. J'ai posé la question
gens au Docteur Karl Weiss à
savoir comment peut bien
distinguer ces termes et ce
qu'ils impliquent, ce qu'il
signifie. D'abord, la
quarantaine, ça fait référence à
l'que lorsqu'on mettait soit des
marins de retour de voyage en
période de quarantaine, donc on
un isolement de 40 jours 10 ans.
Aujourd'hui, c'est différent.
Quand on parle une quarantaine,
selon le Docteur Weiss, on est
plus dans l'ordre de la
sémantique. On sous-entend qu'il
y a un groupe de personnes qui
sont mises à l'écart que ce soit
dans une région, un district,
une localité. Ça peut être pour
une école, ou un groupe de
voyageurs. Ce qu'on a remarqué
dans les dernières semaines en
Italie et ensuite dans
l'ensemble de la botte qui était
mise en quarantaine. Maintenant,
le terme isolement.
L'organisation mondiale de la
santé recommande que les
personnes en isolement soient
dans les chambres individuelles
avec des portes closes, que le
contact soit restreint, voire
interdit, que le déplacement
soit limité et dans le cas plus
sévères, les visites devraient
se faire dans avec des
équipements de protection. Il y
a d'ailleurs une adolescente en
Ontario qui est dans ce type
d'isolement. Elle a fait un
voyage à son retour elle
présentait des symptômes, donc
elle a été mise en isolement
dans sa résidence en Ontario.
Des contacts restreints avec des
membres de la famille, on lui
apportait l'épicerie, les
denrées nécessaires. Le
troisième terme, la
distanciation sociale, ça fait
référence à tous les mesures
d'hygiène, le télétravail. Pour
garder une certaine distance
avec les individus. Certes
indice de six pieds, d'autres
disent entre un et 2 m. Regarder
quelques vidéos que j'ai
trouvées pour vous. Ça c'est à
Rome aujourd'hui. Le spectateur
aujourd'hui qui a décidé d'y
aller avec une notion d'humour.
Ou encore du côté du Pentagone,
un peu plus tôt, voyez la
distance qu'illustre ce sur le
journaliste. Même chose pour ce
qui prennent la parole qui se
sont éloignés. Ce sont des
mesures dits barrières qu'on
utilise pour aplanir cette
fameuse courbe, c'est-à-dire
pour que le nombre de cas soit
sur une plus grande échelle de
temps et surtout que ce nombre
soit moins élevé afin de ne pas
dépasser le seuil critique de ce
que le réseau de santé a comme
capacité maximale.
- Retour de la pose va nous
expliquer concrètement ce que ça
Alors c'est M. Trudeau qui
expliquait cette situation toute
nouvelle. Il devra vivre à la
maison. Mais comment tout ça se
doit doit se passer à
l'intérieur de la maison? Vous
êtes microbiologiste
infectiologue, vous êtes venu
souvent sur notre plateau. Ce
soir vous ne pouvez pas y être.
C'est vous qui avez lancé l'idée
de certaines consignes quant au
ou mesure de sécurité. Vous êtes
en isolement volontaire et en
attente de résultats. Comment ça
doit se passer?
- La différence, c'est que chez
nous, mon mari n'est pas positif
encore. Il a des symptômes, on
est de retour de voyage, il a
été testé. On attend les
résultats. Pas tout à fait
encore dans le même ordre.
Maintenant, comment faire? On
s'est séparé de corps. Lui il a
prie la chambre et moi j'ai pris
le lit à deux étages du fiston
qu'on avait gardé. La salle de
bains de la chambre de maître,
je l'ai laissé à mon mari et moi
j'ai pris la salle de bains avec
les enfants. On est quand même
chanceux, parce qu'on a une
maison qui est assez grande pour
nous permettre d'avoir des salle
de bain dédié. Dans la journée,
nous on a travaillé toute la
journée. C'est pas parce qu'on
est à la maison.
- Vous faites du télétravail.
- J'ai été en lien avec
l'hôpital de la journée et avec
différents médias.
- Votre mari ne peut pas
s'approcher de personnes, il
faut qu'il reste enfermé dans la
chambre?
- Il a mis un masque, il se lave
les mains. Il est toujours à
distance, il est pas collé sur
les enfants. Il tousse pas trop,
donc ça va.
- Si on va du côté d'Ottawa ou
Madame Grégoire-Trudeau à la
COVID-19, elle, elle doit rester
nécessairement dans une seule
pièce, utiliser une seule salle
de bains, pas approcher
personne? Qu'en est-il pour
elle?
- Idéalement, une salle de bain
dédié, des quartiers qui lui
sont plus réservés. Je sais pas
si elle a des masques ou pas.
C'est ce que la transmission...
- on pourrait penser que oui.
- La transmission se fait par
gouttelettes de contact, donc si
nos sécrétions respiratoires ne
sortent pas plus loin que le
masque est ce qu'on se lave les
mains à chaque fois qu'on se
mouche, déjà ça c'est très bien.
On est quand même capable, quand
on est à la maison, de faire
plus attention. On peut décider,
dans un coin de la maison, de
faire moins attention et de
contaminer notre environnement,
il va falloir qu'on nettoie cet
environnement. On s'assoit, mais
si on s'assoit, on est en
zigzag. Il est pas devant moi,
il va être en diagonale. S'ils
12, ça ira pas vers moi. Hier
soir, il mangeait dans la
cuisine et j'ai mangé dans la
salle à dîner.
- Une autre question. Madame
Trudeau Grégoire, elle, est
atteint de la COVID-19. On ne
sait pas quand elle va être
guérie. Monsieur Trudeau se met
en isolement pour 14 jours, mais
elle peut être guérie juste dans
trois semaines. C'est possible.
Est-ce que lui, c'est certain
que dans 14 jours, il va sortir
même si elle est pas guérie?
Comment définit la guérison?
- En fait, il y a un article qui
a été publié aujourd'hui ou hier
où on voit que le virus continu
à être excrété quand même assez
longtemps, parfois jusqu'à 21
jours après le début des
symptômes. Souvent, quatre à
cinq jours après la fin des
symptômes. J'imagine qu'en
théorie, on constate quelqu'un
guéri quand on note de tests de
recherche de virus négatif à 24
heures d'intervalle. J'imagine
que Madame Grégoire-Trudeau va
passer ces tests et séquences
épaisseurs seront déclarées.
Négatifs.. en théorie, 14 jours
de Monsieur Trudeau
commenceraient à la fin de la
période de contagiosité de
Madame. Les 14, c'est-à-dire à
partir du dernier moment où tu
pourrais être infecté.
Autrement... disons que le pire
scénario, ça serait qu'il le
contracte à la dernière journée
où elle elle excrète le virus.
Lui il serait déjà en incubation
de jours après.
- Ça veut dire des semaines, ça?
- Ça peut aider semaines,
effectivement. En même temps,
moins on est symptomatique,
moins on excrète. Je connais
police mesure de santé publique
pour déclarer, pour décréter la
durée d'isolement du conjoint de
quelqu'un qui serait malade. Je
les ai pas vus encore.
- La question des enfants
maintenant, quel est la règle
pour les enfants? Ça serait
formidable si ni votre mari
niveau était atteint de la
COVID-19, mais si vous l'êtes-
vous d'eux, vous devez vous
occuper des enfants avec des
max, de la protection. Et les
enfants doivent être en
quarantaine.
- Mes enfants sont grands et
sont capables de se gérer tout
seul. Il pourrait même faire à
manger.
- Profitez-en. C'est pas encore
une quarantaine, que vous
pourriez apprendre que vous êtes
négatif tout le :
- j'ai pas été testée, parce que
je n'ai pas de symptômes. C'est
juste mon mari qui a été testé.
- Tant mieux si le test est
négatif. Merci de nous avoir
expliqué les contraintes, les
consignes, les règles à suivre
pour vivre cet isolement que
certains Québécois vont devoir
vivre pendant les prochaines
semaines.
- On a un peu peur. Peur
des foules, peur d'attraper...
On veut rester chez nous, là.
- Si tout le monde est en train
d'acheter comme ça, moi aussi,
je vais acheter trois paquets.
- On ne prévoit aucune pénurie
de nourriture. Donc c'est
important que les gens
s'inquiètent pas.
Les épiceries vont continuer
d'être approvisionnées.
Il y a désormais 189 cas
probables ou confirmés
de coronavirus au Canada.
On l'a vu, Ottawa a annoncé
à son tour des mesures
draconiennes pour contrer
la propagation.
Mais les provinces font aussi
leur part. On va faire un survol
de la situation d'est en ouest
avec Wildinette Paul à Moncton,
Davide Gentile à Montréal,
Sébastien St-François à Toronto
et Kim Vermette à Vancouver.
On apprend par ailleurs à
l'instant que Via Rail
interrompt son service entré
Halifax et Montréal, et Toronto
et Vancouver pour freiner la
propagation. Au Nouveau-
Brunswick, on vient d'annoncer
certaines fermetures.
- Les les écoles publiques de la
province vont être fermées dès
lundi pour une période de deux
semaines. Une situation qu'on va
donc réévaluer. Pour ce qui est
des garderies. Il n'y a aucune
indication à ce sujet donc elle
reste ouverte. C'est sans trop
de surprise, parce que déjà
plutôt aujourd'hui, on a
mentionné que si le gouvernement
allait en ce sens, c'est-à-dire
de fermer ses écoles publiques,
qu'elle allait appuyer sa
décision. Je vous invite à
écouter Monsieur Blake et qui a
L'Atlantique est encore épargné,
mais les provinces...
- un peu épargné. On a déjà un
cas recensé au Nouveau-
Brunswick. Les autres provinces
se prépareraient et anticipent
d'avoir plusieurs autres cas de
si les prochaines semaines, même
prochains jours. On parle de
mesures qui sont mises en place.
On parle par exemple de cette
recommandation d'annuler ou
éviter tout événement de plus de
250 personnes. Des restrictions
par rapport aux visites dans le
sol les foyers de soins. Je vais
terminer en vous disant que le
premier ministre de l'Ile-du-
Prince-Édouard est présentement
- Québec et promet de régler le
cafouillage de la ligne Info-
Santé.
- Mme McCann était fâché, parce
qu'effectivement, ça
fonctionnait mal hier. Notre
collègue a attendu deux heures
avant de finalement parler à
quelqu'un. C'était non pas une
infirmière, mais une
travailleuse sociale. On exagère
pas en disant qu'il y a eu des
ratés aujourd'hui. Mme McCann a
dit oublié les 81, c'est le
fameux Daniel Megan Tandy
qu'elle allait s'occuper
personnellement de régler ce
DANIELLE McCANN, ministre Santé
et Services sociaux, Québec
- Mais ce que je veux dire aussi
à la population, c'est qu'il
nous manquait du personnel
à l'Info-Santé. Mais là,
je peux dire aux gens qu'on va
avoir 88 infirmières de plus
dès maintenant au service
d'Info-Santé pour répondre.
Alors, c'est un engagement que
je prends. Il va être réglé,
ce problème-là, aujourd'hui
même. Je vais suivre ça
personnellement.
Est-ce que vous l'avez réessayé
dernièrement le numéro?
- On me dit que ça fonctionne au
moment où on se parle.
- Hier, il nous disait que
c'était pas 24 heures. Peut-être
ils devront en venir à une
prolongation des arts également.
Cela dit, les clés de ce
dépistage, ça va augmenter au
Québec?
- Ça va augmenter de manière
considérable. On ne dit que ça
va passer de trois à 15
cliniques à partir de quand on,
on ne laissait pas trop. Une
chose certaine, parce qu'on
augmente le nombre de cliniques,
il faut aussi augmenter la
capacité d'analyse des tests.
Ça, ça va être multiplié par 16.
On veut tenter de se donner les
outils pour attaquer de front le
COVID-19 et Mme McCann a même
dit que s'il le fallait, on
allait retarder des opérations
pour s'assurer de mettre des
ressources à cet endroit.
Dans les cieux se délaissent de
l'île de Montréal, on interdira
les visites dans le CHSLD et les
hôpitaux pour protéger les
personnes âgées. On écoute l'a
dit le directeur général du
CIUSSS délaisse de l'île de
SYLVAIN LEMIEUX, pdg, CIUSSS
de l'Est-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- Tout ce qui est de soins
de fin de vie, des raisons
de naissance, ça, c'est
d'autres permissions spéciales
que l'on va gérer à la pièce.
Mais le message global,
c'est qu'on limite
l'accès à nos milieux
hospitaliers et CHSLD.
- Une semaine qui a commencé
dans une tout autre ambiance,
mais mercredi et jeudi, senti
qu'une certaine panique c'est
installé dans le réseau de la
santé. Sébastien, à Toronto, la
ville vient d'annoncer de
nouvelles mesures.
- En Ontario, aujourd'hui, on
est à 81 cas. Incluant ceux de
Trenton. Beaucoup de mesures
annoncées au niveau provincial,
entre pas de rassemblement de
plus de 250 personnes. C'est une
recommandation officielle de la
Santé publique de l'Ontario on a
pu visiter aujourd'hui les
centres d'urgence. Pas de
rassemblement de plus de 250
personnes. Des rassemblements
plus petits. On suggère aux
organisateurs est de surveiller
ce que ça peut donner avec leur
santé publique régionale. Il
doit se soumettre aux directives
du fédéral et aussi de sa propre
médecin hygiéniste en chef qui
qui a recommandé que tous les
gens qui viennent de l'extérieur
du pays devraient se mettre en
quarantaine pour 14 jours. On va
aussi réduire la fréquence des
transports en commun. On ferme
les bibliothèques, les piscines
municipales, le centre
communautaire. Beaucoup de
mesures comme ça à Toronto et en
Ontario aujourd'hui.
- Et des employés du secteur de
la santé aimeraient que le
gouvernement fasse davantage.
- Je peux vous dire que je
discute avec des gens du secteur
de la santé depuis presque six
semaines maintenant et il y a
des mesures comme susurrer à
l'oreille qu'on aurait voulu
voir mettre en place beaucoup
plus tôt et qui commence à être
mis en place en ce moment. Il y
a bien bien des gens qui ont une
dent contre le gouvernement de
Monsieur Ford. Je vous laisse
indiquer un des plus grands
patrons du secteur de la santé.
- Smolski Thomas qui est reconnu
pour son franc-parler en
Ontario. Si vous pensez que
c'est sécuritaire, si vous
pensez qu'on devrait faire le
travail, allez-y vous, à le
nettoyer et devinez quoi, ils
n'y vont pas nettoyer ça. Ça
vous donne une idée du temps qui
prévaut en Ontario. Je termine
en vous disant qu'il y a aussi
des délais pour la ligne Info-
Santé en Ontario. De quatre à
cinq heures en ce moment.
- Est-ce qu'on prévoit corriger
la situation?
- Oui c'est ce qu'on prévoit.
- Merci beaucoup Sébastien. Kim,
maintenant. On vient d'annoncer
11 nouveaux cas.
- La bonne nouvelle, selon les
autorités, ce qu'ils y a six
personnes sont maintenant
rétablis de ce virus. Ils y a
plusieurs mesures sont mis en
place ici. On interdit le
rassemblement de plus de 250
personnes. Ça a conduit à
l'annulation de plusieurs
événements. On recommande
Britanno colombien de d'éviter
tout voyage non dénoncé non
essentiel. Selon lui, la
solution, ça réside dans le fait
de faire davantage de tests de
- Ce qu'il nous manque,
maintenant, ce sont des données
sur l'étendue de l'épidémie,
puis pour ça, il va falloir
faire de plus en plus
de dépistage. Je pense
que c'est là qu'on doit insister
pour la semaine à venir.
Puis si un cas est dépisté,
d'avoir en place des mesures
de santé publique urgentes.
Il n'est pourtant pas question
de fermer les écoles en
Colombie-Britannique
- pas pour l'instant. Il y a la
majorité des élèves qui débutent
la relâche scolaire. Ce que dit
le gouvernement et les
autorités, c'est que des
discussions sont en cours et
qu'on réfléchit à la possibilité
de fermer éventuellement les
écoles. Tout ça selon le vol
vision des choses.
- Merci à tous. Merci beaucoup.
Maintenant, je vais poursuivre
avec vos questions avec mes
invités, le Docteur Alain
Poirier qui est dans le studio à
Sherbrooke. Pascal Brion,
psychologue et Docteur Cécile
Tremblay, microbiologiste.
Espèce d'avoir une mise à jour
concernant les essais Patrick de
divers médicaments que les
scientifiques
les travaux avancent rapidement
en ce qui concerne le vaccin. Ça
prend toujours du temps les
évaluer. Safran une phase un,
une phase deux, une face... ça
prend du temps avant qu'on en
trouve un qui va être efficace.
Pour ce qui est des médicaments,
il y a des études qui sont
faites en Chine. Il y a des
essais cliniques où on a essayé
de médicaments. Certains
sembleraient avoir une activité
contre les souches de
coronavirus. Et on ne sera pas
avant plusieurs semaines ou mois
s'ils sont vraiment efficaces
chez le patient.
- Donc il n'y a rien à court
terme.
- Il faut surtout se méfier de
ce qui circule sur Internet. Des
gens qui veulent vous vendre des
médicaments des produits qui
seraient actifs contre le
coronavirus. C'est pas le cas.
- Un mot en réaction avec ce qui
a été mentionné ici au Québec.
La vie nous apprend que les
tests de dépistage vont
augmenter, que la ligne apprécie
bien fonctionner. Que dites-vous
aux spectateurs qui veulent en
savoir plus sur leur état de
santé? Ont-ils le droit de
réclamer un dépistage?
- Il n'y a pas de transmission
locale, donc il ne devrait pas y
avoir tant d'appels, tant de
gens qui vont le réclamer, mais
quand est-ce qu'on peut le
réclamer? Le premier critère :
avons-nous voyagé? A-t-on le
symptôme? Fièvre, température,
etc. Pour l'instant, ce sont les
critères. Le jour où il y aura
transmission reconnue,
identifier ici. Il faut
constamment ajuster ses
indications, mandat
d'aujourd'hui, ça n'a pas
beaucoup changé.
- D'ici la fin du mois, les
tests de dépistage vont
augmenter. On va déployer de
nouvelles cliniques à travers le
Québec.
- Exact. Évidemment, c'est un
nouveau test. La plupart de nos
grands centres hospitaliers sont
capables de faire ce type de
test. Au début, notre
laboratoire national de santé
publique a dû valider chaque
test à Winnipeg. Maintenant que
c'est bien clair et validé. On
transfère, les appareils sont
pas toujours les mêmes. Ce qu'on
a développé au laboratoire de
santé publique, on a dû le
développer... il y a un défi de
faire que d'autres centres... il
y a une centaine de cas au
laboratoire de santé publique.
- Avant de la la pause, il y a
tellement de choses qui ont été
dites depuis le début de cette.
Cette inquiétude, le
comportement aussi, on entendit
les gens de dire à quel point
ils envahissaient les épiceries.
Ça manifestcette inquiétude.
- Il faut l'entendre. C'est
inhabituel, mais c'est aussi
courant. On l'a vu dans tous les
autres pays où ça s'est produit,
donc on est pas anormaux par
rapport aux autres pays. Par
contre, je pense qu'il faut
entendre cette inquiétude de la
population, maître de mesurant
place pour augmenter notre
résidence sociale et puis peut-
être faire une grande
distinction, je pense qu'il y a
une confusion sociale sur
enferme les écoles, entrer ça,
et l'isolement personnel
préventif, l'isolement curatif
de la quarantaine préventive
comme on l'a connu en Italie.
Les gens ont tout de suite
interprété les mesures mises en
place par le gouvernement comme
étant une possibilité de
quarantaine aussi stricte que
celle qu'on voit en Italie alors
que ce n'est pas du tout le cas.
Je pense qu'il reste beaucoup
d'informations à donner pour
pouvoir augmenter cette
résilience.
- Et pour aplanir la fameuse
courbe
. On valide on va l'utiliser
souvent cette expression.
- On parle quarantaine,
d'isolement, comment vivre la
situation, comment vous
accompagnez dans cette nouvelle
réalité de. Que peut-on faire
- Qu'est-ce qui arrive? Est-ce
qu'on est obligé de forcer
des vacances? Est-ce qu'on va
avoir du chomage? Comment
l'argent va rentrer? Je pense
que ça, ça commence à être
un gros stress.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- D'abord, ça va être annoncé
rapidement puis il va être
applicable immédiatement. Ils
seront pas dans une situation
qui mettrait leur famille
à risque financièrement.
BILL MORNEAU, ministre
des finances Canada
- On va avoir des mesures
de relance fiscale, ça, c'est
très important pour rassurer
les gens qu'ils vont avoir
l'argent nécessaire de continuer
d'être dans une bonne position
pour eux et leurs familles.
Quelques extraits des annonces
du jour.
Le ministre des Finances,
Bill Morneau, a annoncé
aujourd'hui des mesures
économiques pour permettre
au Canada de faire face
à la pandémie de COVID-19.
Le gouvernement met en place
un programme de facilitation
du crédit de 10 milliards
de dollars pour soutenir
les entreprises canadiennes.
La Banque du Canada a aussi
annoncé une diminution du taux
directeur, qui passe de 1,25
à 0,75 %. Est-ce que ce sera
suffisant? Quel est le point
de vue des employeurs? Quels
sont les droits des employés?
Je joins à Québec Yves-Thomas
Dorval, président et chef
de la direction du Conseil
du patronat du Québec.
Marianne Plamondon est aussi
avec nous. Elle est avocate en
droit du travail et présidente
sortante de l'Ordre des
conseillers en ressources
humaines du Québec. Bonsoir.
Je vais commencer avec vous M.
Dorval à Québec. Les mesures
annoncées à Québec et à Ottawa
pour le moment vous inspire-t-
elle confiance pour l'avenir qui
est tellement incertain?
- C'est un pas dans la bonne
direction. Il y a eu des
informations au niveau de l'aide
aux employés et aux entreprises
annoncées par le fédéral en
début de semaine. Plus d'un
nouveau programme en matière de
garantie de prêt ou d'aide au
crédit, la baisse du taux
directeur bien sûr, mais il ira
d'autres éléments ou d'autres
qui vont suivre. Au Québec, on
s'attarde aux questions de
prévention, des précautions en
termes de santé publique. Les
entreprise en trois rôles. Il y
a un rôle comme entreprise de
produire et de fournir des
produits et des services à des
des produits et des services à
des clients. Comment je peux
assur lorsqu'on sait qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup d'absentéisme que
la clientèle diminue? Il y a une
responsabilité sociale, une
solidarité sociale, comment les
employeurs et le milieu de
travail Er la continuité de mes
participer justement Er la
mécanismes de prévention et de
précaution Er la continuité de
publique? Er la continuité de
des responsabilités de santé et
sécurité au travail pour assurer
des milieux de travail cinq Er
sécuritaire. Er la continuité de
mes opération
- le premier ministre Legault
hier appelle les employeurs, les
patrons à être compréhensif. Ça
veut dire payer des salaires
mêmes s'ils rendent pas de
service, ça va jusqu'où dans
votre esprit?
- En fait, chaque employeur à
une situation particulière. Il y
a d'abord une question de droits
et d'obligations et de
responsabilité. Au-delà de ça,
les employeurs, c'est ce qui est
suggéré, les PDG sont au
courant, c'est de faire preuve
d'empathie, de compréhension et
de flexibilité pour essayer
d'accommoder. De toute façon,
les employeurs sont aux prises
avec des obligations de
continuité de service. Ils ont
tout intérêt, c'est ce qu'ils
font, à faire en sorte de
protéger, d'aider leur main-
d'oeuvre, ressources humaines
pour faire en sorte d'éviter le
plus possible les enjeux de
production qu'il va y avoir
indéniablement. C'est un secteur
extrêmement touché. Il y a des
demandes qu'on a formulées
aujourd'hui, on a envoyé nos
demandes au fédéral et au
provincial parce qu'on consulte
régulièrement nos membres, sur
différents types d'interventions
qui devraient être faites, qui
va bien au-delà de ce qui se
fait à ce moment-ci, toujours en
considérant qu'ils ont un rôle
de responsabilité. La première
responsabilité au niveau de la
santé publique, c'est de
s'assurer que leurs activités ne
contribuent pas à la propagation
du virus au niveau de la
communauté.
- Madame Plamondon, de votre
côté, quelles sont vos attentes?
Les employés vivent énormément
d'inquiétude notamment pour
leurs salaires et d'autres
aspects du travail.
- Le premier élément, c'est la
communication. Les employeurs
s'ils veulent bien traverser
cette crise, on s'entend qu'il y
a des enjeux financiers très
importants pour certains
employeurs dans certains
secteurs. C'est très important
de communiquer les choses très
clairement, donc par exemple le
fait que l'hygiène devient
vraiment une obligation.
Obligation de se laver les mains
quand on arrive au milieu de
travail, de façon sporadique aux
ordinaires, on revient, on se
lave les mains. Donc ce genre de
choses, on est rendu là. Et
d'avoir le matériel pour ce
désinfecter, tout ça. Et
désinfecter davantage le milieu
de travail aussi. Aussi
évidemment éviter tout voyage à
l'extérieur du Canada. Et pour
ce qui est des voyages
personnels, c'est quand même une
question qui revient à l'heure
actuelle, quelqu'un qui décide
d'aller à l'étranger malgré tout
ce qu'on a entendu, les
directives du gouvernement du
fait que l'on ne le conseille
pas. L'employé va être mis en
quarantaine, c'est pas clair que
l'employé va pouvoir toucher son
salaire. Essai à chaque fois des
cas différents. Mais ça peut
durer longtemps. Si la personne
présente des symptômes, elle est
peut-être partie pour une
quarantaine de moi. Les
employeurs ne pourront pas
prendre fait et cause pour ses
employés qui ont décidé de
quitter le pays. Par ailleurs,
tout événement, conférences,
colloques, réunions devraient
être annulées à moins que ce
soit nécessaire. On devrait
procéder le plus possible par
appel vidéoconférence de façon à
éviter tout rassemblement de
toutes natures. Les employeurs
devraient donner la directive
que tout rassemblement même au
niveau personnel est fortement
déconseillé.
- Les mariages en fin de
semaine, 125 invités, qu'est-ce
que tu fais?
- C'est problématique. On peut
s'attendre qu'il va y avoir des
absences. Les gens n'ont pas le
goût de se retrouver avec des
problèmes après. Une fois qu'on
est infecté, avant de revenir au
travail, on ne parle pas de deux
semaines, on part du processus
complet jusqu'à tant qu' on soit
sûr. On pourra pas réintégrer
n'importe qui en milieu de
travail il va falloir que la
personne ait un certificat
médical d'aptitude au travail.
Sinon l'employeur pourrait
réintégrer des gens éviter.
- Quelles sont vos craintes, M.
Dorval, face à vos employés?
- La première des choses,
notre collègue ici à préparer
abondamment de plusieurs
mesures. La première crainte :
est-ce que je garde mon milieu
de travail sain et sécuritaire,
c'est ma première
responsabilité. Qu'est-ce que je
fais pour ça? La première
préoccupation est de s'assurer
qu'ils soient au courant des
situations. C'est pas facile à
gérer parce qu'il faut poser des
questions parfois. On peut pas
poser des questions si on a pas
de doute raisonnable. Il y a
plein d'éléments complexes à
gérer. Comme on l'a dit tantôt,
la transparence dans la
communication et la clé.
L'employeur doit avoir une
transparence dans sa
communication et les employés
doivent avoir une transparence
dans leur communication. Cela
dit, il y a des secteurs
industriels, les secteurs de
l'économie actuellement qui sont
aux prises non seulement avec
des problèmes de présence ou qui
vont avoir des problèmes à
partir de la semaine prochaine.
Toutes les écoles, la garderie
ferme, que va-t-il arriver avec
les employés qui ont déjà des
enjeux à gérer du côté santé
publique. Mais de voir s'occuper
de la famille aussi, il y a une
grande crainte sur la capacité
d'assurer la continuité de
service d'une part. D'autre
part, il y a des industries qui
sont là et touchées de manière
majeure. L'industrie du
tourisme, les transporteurs
aériens, les hôtels, les centres
de congrès, les événements,
toutes les régions, l'industrie
touristique est un élément
extrêmement important pour
toutes les régions du Québec. Si
je prends cet exemple, la
production agroalimentaire,
c'est la même chose. On doit
assurer la fourniture des
denrées pour la population.
Comment on fait au niveau de la
production, distribution, la
vente et même de la production?
En plus de ça, on arrive à la
période des semis. Comment on
peut s'assurer d'avoir la main-
d'oeuvre pour les semis. Il y a
la question des travailleurs
saisonniers.
- En effet. Donc pour vous
demander en terminant très
rapidement M. Dorval les mesures
économiques pour faire des
prêts, les deux gouvernements
ont dit qu'ils seraient là pour
soutenir tout le monde. Vous y
croyez?
- Je pense que les gouvernements
ont fait très bien au tout début
de dire que la question de santé
publique et au départ. La
deuxième, d'avancer certains
programmes, mais il y a beaucoup
à faire. Il y aura énormément de
dommages. Il faut assurer des
revenus aux employés qui seront
absents et pour les entreprises,
pour qu'elle puisse continuer à
assumer leur productivité, leur
production.
- Merci M. Dorval, merci Madame
Plamondon.
Ailleurs dans le monde,
l'Éthiopie, le Kenya et le Ghana
ont rapporté leur premier cas.
De nombreux pays emboîtent
le pas avec des mesures
exceptionnelles.
Voici quelques-unes
des nouvelles de cette autre
journée de pandémie,
résumée en 60 secondes.
- Nous allons faire passer
cette limite aux rassemblements
de 100 personnes.
(en anglais)
(en espagnol)
Donald Trump déclare l'état
d'urgence. Y a-t-il des lacunes
dans la gestion de la crise,
aux États-Unis? Restez
avec nous.
Donald Trump déclare l'état
d'urgence pour accroître
la capacité des États-Unis
à combattre la COVID-19.
Finit-il par prendre au sérieux
cette pandémie?
Pour analyser la gestion de
cette crise par l'administration
Trump, nous joignons
à Sherbrooke Karine Prémont,
politologue à l'Université
de Sherbrooke.
On a entendu que c'était un
échec le dépistage. Donald Trump
dit que c'est pas un échec, on
est les meilleurs. Hier il
disait : on a 32 morts alors
qu'il y en avait 38. Votre
évaluation de la gestion de la
crise?
- C'est une très mauvaise
gestion des crises. C'est une
gestion de crise qui a pris du
temps à se mettre en branle. Au
début, il y a quelques semaines,
Donald Trump minimiser la crise
en disant qu'il y aurait un
vaccin bientôt. Les gens de son
entourage disaient que ce un
canular démocrate ou en tout cas
une crise amplifiée par les
démocrates. Évidemment, on a un
mois de retard à partir de ce
moment. Le premier cas est
apparu probablement fin janvier
ou début février. C'est très
tard pour gérer une crise de
cette ampleur. Les mesures ont
dû être prises de façon un peu
aléatoire par les villes et les
états en l'absence de réaction
du fédéral. Aujourd'hui, enfin,
on annonce l'état d'urgence avec
ce qui vient avec, des
ressources financières et
humaines, l'autorité nécessaire
pour mettre en place des mesures
plus adéquates.
- Vous avez senti que Donald
Trump avait plus à coeur
l'économie de la santé des
Américains?
Quand on révélait les faiblesses
du système de dépistage
notamment, la fin de certains
programmes pour contrer les
pandémie. Il a toujours dit
qu'il ne connaissait pas, c'est
pas de sa faute s'il était
abandonné. Il renvoie tout cela
aux autres.
- Il renvoie ça aux autres. Il a
accusé Barack Obama ou son
administration d'avoir changé
les règles de réaction aux
crises. Alors que quand on se
rappelle du H1N1 1 million de
personnes avait été testé dans
le premier mois. On n'a pas les
chiffres, c'est ce qui est
inquiétant quand même à l'heure
actuelle, les experts parlent de
moins de 10 000 personnes qui
ont été testées probablement à
l'heure actuelle. Donald Trump a
mis du temps à réagir pour des
raisons économiques comme vous
dites. Chaque fois que la crise
s'envenimait, la bourse plongée.
On sait à quel point pour Donald
Trump, il prend sa personnel
quand la bourse plongée. Donc il
essayait de minimiser un peu
l'impact que ça pouvait avoir au
niveau économique. Avec le
projet de loi de la chambre, je
sais pas si les républicains de
la chambre l'ont soutenu pour
l'instant, mais cela permet de
regarnir les coffres pour
permettre aux gens d'être testé.
Ça devrait aider.
- Vous croyez qu'il y aura un
impact de sa gestion de crise
sur sa popularité et ses chances
de réaction?
- Tout dépend de la durée de la
crise. Si elle devait se
résorber rapidement, peut-être
qu'il aurait le temps d'ici
novembre de rétablir un peu sa
cote de popularité. Pour
l'instant, c'est difficile pour
lui. Il ne gère pas bien la
crise. Il n'y a plus de parti
politique, on est affecté au
niveau de la santé quand les
gens se demandent s'ils ont les
moyens de rester à la maison,
qu'ils soient malades ou pas,
évidemment peut comprendre que
ça a un impact peut-être sur la
personne qu'il juge responsables
de la crise. Si ça devait
s'envenimer, évidemment on peut
imaginer que ça aurait un impact
sur les urnes. On verra si ça
dure dans le temps comment cette
élection se tiendra ou pas. Il
faudra sûrement rediscuter
aussi.
- Est-ce que Donald Trump en
étant privés des grands rallyes
qui le rentent si effervescents
pour accuser tout le monde et
faire valoir ses idées, son
plan, on est les meilleurs,
comme touchant, on peut penser
que c'est une arme en moins pour
lui. Ça peut l'affecter de ce
point de vue.
- Ça peut l'affecter parce que
pour lui ça fonctionne bien les
grands rallyes. Il risque d'être
plus actif sur Twitter dans les
prochaines semaines. Il faudra
surveiller de plus près ce qu'il
va dire sur Twitter. Ce sera à
peu près tout ce qui va lui
rester en ce moment.
- Les démocrates, comment ils
peuvent tirer leur épingle du
jeu? Un débat sur l'importance
d'avoir un système de santé
universel, est-ce que ce n'est
pas révélateur justement des
besoins clients aux États-Unis
pour un système de santé plus
justes et accessibles.
- Tout à fait. Je pense que
Bernie Sanders a une fenêtre
d'opportunité malgré le côté
sombre de cette affaire. On
démontre par l'exemple concret
la nécessité de tenir un système
de santé qui permet aux gens de
pas se poser des questions.
Combien d'Américains n'ont pas
pu se faire testé ces dernières
semaines parce qu'il se disait
qu'il n'avait pas les moyens d'y
aller. Avec le projet de loi qui
est proposée, on va permettre
aux gens de se faire testé peu
importe ils ont une assurance.
Va permettre Bernie Sanders de
clarifier son message. On en a
besoin en tout temps.
Évidemment, Joe Biden a fait un
discours assez remarqué il y a
quelques jours. Un discours
rassembleur, un discours de chef
d'État, il tentait de rassurer
tout le monde. Encore une fois,
on verra l'impact que ça aura en
novembre. C'est encore très
loin. On verra que les taxes
pourraient avoir sur les gens.
La Louisiane avait décidé de
reporter son élection primaire
en juin alors qu'elle devait
avoir lieu en avril. Si d'autres
états devaient faire la même
chose, on devrait se poser la
question du momentum des
démocrates.
- Il y a un débat dimanche soir.
- Sans public.
- Ce qui pensait que Bernie
Sanders allait se retirer de la
course pourrait être déçue. Le
débat va être important dans le
contexte actuel. C'est la
panique aussi.
- C'est la panique. Je pense que
c'est un débat important, ce
sera le premier avec deux
personnes. Ça va être
intéressant à ce point de vue.
On verra quelles solutions
concrètes les deux hommes
proposent aux Américains dans le
cas de la COVID-19 mais plus
largement en termes de santé. Je
pense que ça va être au coeur du
débat.
- Merci beaucoup. On se reparle
la semaine prochaine.
- Merci.
J'ai toujours mon panel
d'experts.
Une question très concrète :
- je crois que c'est une
question que beaucoup de
personnes ont en tête. C'est
pour ça qu'on voit la course
dans les épiceries et qu'on
achète des tonnes de rouleaux de
papier de toilette. Je pense que
c'est un symbole de se sentir
sécuritaire et de faire quelque
chose de concret pour se
préparer. Les chances que les
gens se retrouvent en isolement
volontaire présentement sont pas
très grandes. Au fur et à mesure
que l'épidémie se développe, si
elle développe avec beaucoup de
transmission, éventuellement il
va y avoir plusieurs personnes
qui vont être en isolement
volontaire. Cela dit, isolement
volontaire, c'est 14 jours, si
on est atteint par la maladie,
ça risque d'être un peu plus
long, maximum un mois à peu
près. Donc quand les gens vont à
l'épicerie et font leur
provision, il faut garder la
même logique. De quoi on a
besoin. En général, dans nos
maisons, on fait des épiceries
et on a de quoi manger plus
qu'une semaine. Alors entriez
aller et remplir les paniers de
toutes sortes de choses dont on
n'a pas besoin ou la logique de
dire : je fais une épicerie,
j'en fais un peu plus, je
m'assure d'avoir suffisamment de
médicaments de prescription pour
un mois, c'est une bonne
conduite de toute façon que les
gens devraient faire. Je pense
qu'avant de partir pour
l'épicerie, il faut réfléchir et
se dire : je vais me préparer,
mais de quoi j'ai vraiment
besoin.
- Je pense qu'on craint la
quarantaine collective. Les gens
craignent de ne pas pouvoir
sortir. Il y a une différence
avec l'isolement volontaire.
Je peux me faire livrer des
choses à la maison, pendant ce
temps-là huit continu à
fonctionner. On est très loin de
penser qu'on va arrêter la ville
complètement en arrêtant tous
les marchés et les épiceries, il
va y avoir l'armée dans les
rues, comme en Italie, si on est
en isolement seul à la maison,
on peut se faire livrer des
choses. Un restaurant proposé de
faire livrer des choses et le
bonus était le rouleau de papier
de toilette.
Il faut pas qu'on se sente dans
une prison dont on ne peut pas
sortir.
- Là-dessus, Docteur Poirier?
- J'avais presque un fou rire en
écoutant. On va pas laisser
mourir les gens de fin, de soif
ou de manque de papier de
toilette parce qu'ils sont en
isolement. Il y a des questions
de livraison, je pense qu'il y
aura toutes sortes de façons de
ces prisonniers, avec des amis.
- On est loin d'un scénario où
on ferme la ville complètement.
- Tout à fait. Qu'allons-nous.
- Même dans un scénario dans
lequel on ferme les villes, les
épiceries et les pharmacies
restaient ouverts, les gens
étaient autorisé à aller
chercher de la nourriture. J'ai
une belle fille dont la famille
est chinoise, tout était fermé
dans leur ville, mais c'était
interdit de fermer les épiceries
et les pharmacies. Les gens
pouvaient y aller un par un pour
aller chercher leurs affaires.
Même si on se retrouve dans une
situation aussi dramatique que
l'Italie ou que l'chinook à la
France, il y aurait des
solutions pour la population.
- Comme dit le Docteur Poirier,
il faut se calmer
rester ave
Ottawa a demandé aux Canadiens
de reporter les voyages
extérieurs d'un essentiel.
Vous nous avez inondé de
questions sur les annulations
de voyage et les remboursements
possibles. J'en parle avec
Charles Tanguay, porte-parole
de l'Office de la protection
du consommateur et Lyne Duhaime,
présidente pour le Québec
de l'Association canadienne
des compagnies d'assurances
de personnes. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
Alors si Julie aimant qui va
vous lancer des questions.
- On a de très nombreuses
questions sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans la boîte
courriel de 24/60. Une question
: est-ce qu'on doit éviter à
tout prix de prendre l'avion
même à l'intérieur du pays ou de
la province? En pense à certains
vols assez importants dans
lequel il y aurait plus de 250
personnes à l'intérieur de
l'appareil. Une première
question. La seconde que je vous
lance : comment a-t-on prévu
accueillir les milliers de
Québécois, de snowbirds qui sont
présentement en Floride, dans le
sud des États-Unis et seront de
retour dans quelques semaines.
Une arrivée massive à prévoir
aux douanes mais également pour
la mise en quarantaine
isolément. Comment avons-nous
prévu accueillir ses vacanciers.
Troisième piste de réflexion
pour vous : on sait que les
États-Unis ont fermé les
barrières, les douanes pour les
voyageurs arrivant d'europe.
Est-ce que le Canada va faire
quelque chose pour ces gens qui
pourraient transiter par notre
pays. En terminant, est-ce qu'on
prévoit rembourser d'une
quelconque façon, compenser
les voyageurs qui avaient acheté
des séjours, des voyages,
toutes sortent de forfaits pour
des destinations qui ne sont pas
nécessairement déconseillées.
Mais donc, pour lesquelles ces
personnes pourraient être plus
frileuses, plus craintif
d'effectuer quand même
le voyage.
Voilà quatre questions rafale
pour vous inviter à Marie.
- Toutes les investigations sont
déconseillées. Il y a une
dimension santé et du
commercial. Je vais commencer
sur la question de la santé.
Docteur Tremblay, peut-être une
des rapidement de quoi il
s'agit. Prendre l'avion, est-ce
que c'est déconseillées?
- C'est déconseillé de prendre
l'avion. Même si la santé
publique du Canada ne dit pas...
interdit pas les voyages à
l'intérieur du pays, je pense
qu'il faut utiliser son gros bon
sens et se dire que dans le
fond, voyager de Montréal à
Vancouver c'est plus loin....
- on a même annulé des trains
pour certain temps. Du côté des
assurances, les gens
s'inquiètent de perdre leur mise
voyages. Il devrait renoncer à
ce moment-ci.
- La décision de voyager, je
pense qu'on a des experts ici.
Pour ce qui est du
remboursement, il y a différents
types de polices d'assurance.
Par exemple il y a des polices
d'assurance annulation toutes
conditions. Généralement les
gens peuvent annuler sans avoir
de justification.
La plupart des polices que les
gens en sont pour des raisons
d'ordre médical ou parce qu'il y
a un avis de niveau 3  ou plus
déclaré par le gouvernement.
Est-ce qu'on est là-dedans?
C'est la question présentement.
Ce matin je vous aurais dit : ça
prend un niveau 3 ou plus pour
avoir une possibilité de se
faire rembourser.
Les polices, dans le contrat, on
se base  sur des avis objectifs
du gouvernement. Le problème
présentement ce que Monsieur
Trudeau a fait une annonce
aujourd'hui et on nous dit :
éviter tout voyage non
essentiel. Sans avoir changé la
cote de risque du pays.
Donc, nous sommes analysés cette
situation. Et à prendre une
position. On est en terrain
inconnu.
- Ça va être du cas par cas
selon son assureur j'imagine.
De votre côté Monsieur Tanguy à
Québec les 19 et de protection
du consommateur.
- Alors de notre côté, on
encadre les agents de voyage
avec la loi sur les agents de
voyage. Elles font indemnisation
des clients des agents de voyage
qui prévoit justement,
un peu comme dans le cas de
l'assurance, la possibilité
d'annuler un voyage de se faire
entièrement remboursé
dans le cas où un avis officiel
du gouvernement fédéral
recommanderait d'éviter
tout voyage non essentiel.
Justement en fin de journée, en
milieu de journée aujourd'hui,
le gouvernement fédéral lançait
que maintenant la vie en
question ou l'avertissement en
question visait tous les pays.
Alors, vraisemblablement, font
indemnisation pour rembourser
tous les voyages achetés d'un
agent de voyages. C'est ça la
condition principale.
Je présume que bien des
téléspectateurs, vont se rendre
compte de l'importance de faire
affaire avec une agence de
voyages et de l'utilité de cette
protection. Alors,
effectivement, les gens qui ont
acheté avant l'avertissement,
ça c'est important, et dans le
voyage doit avoir lieu alors que
l'avertissement sera toujours en
vigueur. Si votre voyager dans
six mois, il est trop tôt pour
vous dire que vous serez
remboursé à 100 % puisqu'on ne
sait pas dans six mois si les
avertissements ne seront pas
levés.
C'est la même chose pour les
croisières. Le gouvernement
fédéral a décommandé...
ou recommandé de ne pas
participer à des croisières.
Ça rentre maintenant dans cette
catégorie des critères
pour un remboursement par le
fonds d'indemnisation des
clients des agents de voyages.
En notant que la date de
croisière soit arrivée et que
l'avertissement soit toujours en
vigueur à la date en question.
- Alors, si on vous met ensemble
tous les deux, les assureurs et
le fils de protection du
consommateur, par le biais des
agences de voyages, mais tous
ceux et celles qui ont acheté
des voyages par Internet comme
c'est la grande mode sans passer
par un agent de voyages se sont
achetés par Internet une
assurance voyage, tant que les
assureurs n'ont pas pris une
position claire, ça pourrait
être une position nationale de
tous les assureurs ensemble qui
pourraient considérer,
comme le dit Monsieur Tangay?
Que c'est un niveau assez élevé
pour rembourser?
- Mon association est canadienne
et en représente tous les
assureurs qui font affaire
Canada. On tente de développer
des bonnes pratiques pour que
dans la mesure du possible,
l'québécois et canadien sache à
quoi s'attendre.
C'est notre objectif.
Mais un de nos enjeux
principaux, c'est que la
situation change d'heure en
heure. Au début de la semaine ça
changeait de jour en jour.
Maintenant c'est d'heure en
heure. C'est la difficulté à
laquelle nous faisons face.
- Mais pour l'instant, il n'y a
pas trop d'espoir de rembourser
tout le monde s'il sans passer
par Internet et non par une
agence de voyages.
- En fait c'est de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec la
déclaration ou la position du
gouvernement à l'effet que nous
devons éviter tout voyage
essentiel. Alors que la façon
dont ça fonctionne dans
plusieurs contrats d'assurance
voyage, pour obtenir une
annulation il faut que le pays
est une cote de 3 au niveau de
son risque. On est en train
d'étudier la situation.
- Est-ce que vous pourriez être
généreux c'est-à-dire contribué
à l'effort économique
et être solidaire de tout le
monde de dire : la cote trois
c'est ici que ça se passe. On ne
veut pas que les Canadiens
aillent dans un pays où il ne
pourrait pas être soigné. Il
développe la maladie, et tombe
dans un système de santé
auxquels ils n'ont pas accès.
- Tout à fait. Nous voulons dans
ce dossier dans cette crise est
un partenaire du gouvernement.
On travaille très fort avec le
gouvernement fédéral pour une
coordination avec les
prestations d'assurance emploi
pour que personne ne se retrouve
entre deux chaises et que les
gens et des prestations
d'assurance emploi ou
d'assurance invalidité.
Présentement il y a un exercice
de coordination entre toutes les
joueurs, les gouvernements,
assureurs, employeurs, office de
protection du consommateur.
- Ça pourrait coûter cher si
vous deviez payer.
- Tout à fait.
Mais ça...
- les gens disent : pour une
fois les assurances vont payer.
Pourquoi en fait de l'assurance
il ne fait jamais quand c'est le
temps.
- Si les gens sont malades ils
auront accès à l'assurance
invalidité. Il y a aussi cet
aspect qu'on regarde
attentivement.
- Docteur Poirier à Sherbrooke,
avez-vous une réflexion là-
dessus. Quand on dit qu'on
devrait participer à l'effort
collectif et solidaire.
Ça génère de l'angoisse aussi.
- Oui, plutôt. Moi-même j'ai
acheté un beau voyage bientôt
avec toute la famille.
Je ne sais pas. J'ai écouté mais
ce n'est pas un agent de voyages
comme vous l'avez dit, c'est
Expedia, voilà.
- Expedia s'en est un.
- Bonne nouvelle pour moi.
Mais bref, je pense que pas mal
de gens doivent réfléchir.
Moi, évidemment, peut-être que
mes ne sont pas aussi comptés
que la majorité des gens.
Mais mon message c'est :
l'importance de respecter les
consignes et l'argent passera en
deuxième. Mais il faudra pour
beaucoup d'autres en trouver...
moi aussi je vais accepter mais
il faudra trouver des solutions
parce que ça pose problème.
- 30 secondes Docteur Tremblay,
les Snowbirds vont revenir.
- Une quarantaine volontaire. Ça
c'est clair. Les gens ont le
temps de préparer le terrain
pour recevoir leurs parents et
leurs grands-parents qui
reviennent de Floride.
- C'est mieux de revenir
maintenant.
- Ce serait mieux de revenir
maintenant...
- parce que là-bas les risques
sont plus grands qu'ici.
- Les risques sont plus grands
qu'ici. En Floride, la situation
évolue chaque jour alors c'est
difficile d'en tenir compte,
mais je pense que ce serait bien
de revenir ici. Comme ça ils ne
seront pas au coeur de la crise.
- Merci beaucoup. Merci Monsieur
Tanguy à Québec et merci Madame.
- Merci à vous.
- On s'en va à la Poser après la
pause, une pose littéraire.
Albert Camus et la peste.
Pourquoi c'est intéressant de
relire cette oeuvre
♪ ♪ ♪
On vous propose une petite pause
littérature de quelques minutes.
Un classique de la littérature
suscite un regain d'intérêt.
Écrit en 1947, La peste d'Albert
Camus raconte la vie quotidienne
d'une ville d'Algérie alors quel
est frappé d'une épidémie de
peste. L'vente de ce célèbre
roman est en forte hausse depuis
le début de l'année 2020.
Ça s'explique, on veut
comprendre pourquoi.
J'accueille l'écrivain Martin,
qui est également médecin.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Pourquoi la peste d'Albert
Camus.
- C'est un roman métaphorique.
Il ne parle pas vraiment d'une
épidémie. Il parle de la France
occupée par les nazis, mais
finalement ce dont il parle
aussi d'une communauté qui est
enfermée et qui ne sait pas
comment survivre à cette
maladie, cette peste noire qui,
bon, et transposée sous la forme
des rats qui transportent la
peste.
- C'est une métaphore.
- Et c'est une métaphore de
savoir ce qu'on fait quand on
est enfermée dans un même lieu
et qu'on est menacé par la même
chose. Il décrit plusieurs
personnages. Docteur, qui est le
personnage central du roman qui
soigne gens malades. Sa mission.
Il y en a d'autres comme Kotar
qui est extrêmement perturbé et
ensuite profite de la misère
des autres. Un autre vient aider
le docteur. Rambert envie de
partir pour retrouver sa femme à
l'extérieur. Il décrit
l'attitude de toutes les
personnes présentes face à ces
dangers. Et c'est un roman qui a
été écrit par un philosophe
qui a écrit le mythe de Sisyphe.
Il parle de l'absurdité de la
vie. Finalement c'est un roman
qui montre comment les gens,
face a une difficulté, chercher
du sens. C'est ce que font les
lecteurs. Il cherche du sens
dans le roman. Et le sens que
Camus donne dans le roman mais
aussi à la fin, il dit :
finalement on a que deux
solutions. Ou bien s'enfuit ou
bien on meurt. ou bien fait
oeuvre collective pour lutter
contre le danger. C'est la
solidarité et le travail
collectif qui aura le plus de
chances de sauver le plus grand
nombre de gens.
- Transposée dans la pandémie
actuelle ce sont des valeurs
qu'on peut transposer.
- Tout à fait. Ce qui est
paradoxal dans la pandémie
actuelle, c'est qu'on nous
demande rien faire.
C'est-à-dire qu'on nous demande
de nous retirer du monde lieu
d'être actif. C'est paradoxal
parce qu'on est dans un monde
dans lequel on nous demande de
faire des choses toujours.
Pour la première fois on ne dit
: non, restez chez vous,
vous devez garder vos distances
avec le monde. C'est ça qui va
être protecteur. C'est
paradoxal. C'est un changement
de paradigme extraordinairement
nouveau. Ça va absolument à
l'encontre de tout ce qui est
recherche de notre croissance,
de la productivité, du profit à
tout prix. Je trouve ça tout à
fait intéressant que les gens à
chercher des réponses dans
Camus. À titre personnel...
- vous avez un lien personnel.
- Mon père était l'ami d'enfance
d'Albert Camus. Il était
médecin. Il a soigné la mère de
Camus. Et il a parlé avec Camus
de sa propre maladie qui était
la tuberculose. Moi c'est
quelque chose qui me touche
beaucoup parce que la figure du
médecin à l'intérieur du livre,
c'est une figure universelle du
soignant. Le soignant c'est la
personne qui décide de ne pas
s'enfiler et de s'occuper des
gens qui souffrent.
- Il y a une belle phrase vers
la fin, "la mort et la vie..."
la mort et le mal nous somme
ensemble pour les combattre".
- Exactement. Il faut être
ensemble pour les combattre.
- En mettant ce qu'on vit
actuellement risque de mettre à
plat tout le système social
économique en tout cas. C'est du
jamais vu, sauf peut-être après
les grandes guerres tout ça. Les
gens qui se questionnent là-bas
: comment va vivre après?
- Je crois que ce que ça va
faire ce que ça va stimuler
beaucoup l'imagination d'une
part et les initiatives.
Je pense que le système actuel
est aussi extrêmement
verrouillé. Il empêche les gens
de faire des choses qu'il
pourrait faire, mais on leur dit
: c'est peut-être pas assez
rentable... alors que là
précisément, comme tout ce qui
est rentable va être ralenti,
il y a des initiatives qui
pourront se mettre en place pour
faire autre chose.
Je pense en tout cas que dans
les pays développés, c'est une
chance extraordinaire de changer
de paradigme et de proposer
d'autres moyens de fonctionner.
- L'valeur principale de ce
roman pour vous?
- C'est la solidarité,
l'entraide et la générosité.
- Et on doit en tirer des
leçons?
- Je crois qu'on peut? On peut
en tirer des leçons.
- Et la résilience aussi
sociale.
- Tout à fait, absolument.
Résister socialement, résister,
je suis en train de lire
un autre livre qui s'appelle
Parisienne, sur la vie des Paris
pendant l'occupation, c'est un
hasard qu'on m'a demandé de
relire La peste.
La résistance sociale, ce n'est
peut-être que le fait de
solidarité. On peut résister
individuellement mais on peut
aussi résister en étant plus
grntil plus accueillant.
On ne va pas pouvoir toucher les
gens et les voir plus souvent,
on peut parler. On est dans un
monde où on peut communiquer. Ce
n'était pas le cas il y a 50
ans.
- Et sur la manière dont on gère
les choses actuellement, comment
vous voyez ça?
- Moi je compare la France, le
Canada et les États-Unis je
trouve qu'on est pas mal ici.
Je lisais par exemple,
la Colombie-Britannique a eu
affaire au SRAS au début des
années 2000. Ils étaient
complètement dépassés ils ont
appris ils ont appris le reste
du Canada comment faire face a
ce genre de choses.
- C'est là qu'il y a le plus
grand nombre de cas.
- Oui parce que c'est là que ça
arrive.
- Merci beaucoup de nous avoir
invité à relire la peste, pour
ceux qui l'ont lu. Fait pas mal
d'années. Restez avec nous,
on continue avec la pose avec
nos invités sur le plateau. Pour
le mot de la fin.
Le temps de conclure cette
émission avec les dernières
questions de Julie et de vous.
- Quelques questions
en rafale pour terminer.
Les gens se questionnent à
savoir si ça vaut la peine, à
cet endroit si dans la crise,
de vraiment renforcer son
système immunitaire.
Est-ce qu'on peut être mieux
protégé pour ne pas attraper la
COVID-19 si on est en contact
avec quelqu'un qui serait
contaminé?
Est-ce que la propagation du
virus peut se faire dans les
conduites de ventilation ou
d'aération?
On a beaucoup de gens qui
habitent dans des tours, des
dans l'aqueduc aussi on se
questionne résidences des tours
à condos.
peuvent être utile ou pertinent
pour nettoyer les surfaces.
- Merci Julie. On n'y va en
rafale. Avec vous Docteur
Tremblay. Renforcer son système
immunitaire.
-
de renforcer le système
immunitaire. En général si on
mange bien, on fait de
l'exercice, notre système
immunitaire devrait combattre
les maladies.
commencer à s'acheter des galons
de vitamine C, ça ne change
rien. Vous allez les uriner.
système, ça n'ajoutera rien.
ventilation?
dit que le virus
se propage par gouttelettes et
par contact. Il faut être proche
de la personne pour être
contaminé. Ventilation ce serait
six, se propager par aérosols,
ce qui n'est pas le cas.
On n'écrit pas par rapport à la
ventilation.
- Docteur vin clair vous disiez
pendant la pause, si c'était
arrivé dans les croisières...
- dans les bateaux tout le monde
était malade.
- Pour vous Docteur Poirier,
le Docteur Arruda disait :
j'ai deux obsessions : aplanir
la fameuse courbe et me laver
les mains. C'est le message
lancé?
- Et j'ai rajouté une autre,
pour rebondir sur la question de
la solidarité, on est un réseau
de santé et des services sociaux
et dans toutes ses épidémies,
ses problèmes, c'est toujours
les plus vulnérables.
Les personnes âgées et les gens
qui vivent seules, qui ont
besoin d'aide. Au moment où on
se prépara acheter une rapide
toilette il faudrait penser aux
gens autour de nous qui vont
avoir des difficultés innovants
pas comprendre les consignes.
C'est souvent pour eux.
Et c'est le cas aussi pour les
plus vulnérables, les gens qui
ont des maladies chroniques
et l'âge. Avec l'âge limité
diminue un peu alors il faut
penser à ces gens.
- Les personnes les plus
vulnérables aussi.
- Oui, j'imagine. Au point de
vue physique.
- Au point de vue mental aussi.
- La question se pose aussi sur
comment socialement va pouvoir
aider la résilients sociale dans
la population.
On traite souvent du trauma
quand il est terminé. La
maintenant on est face à des
l'adversités. On a un pouvoir
sur la capacité de résilience
- Comment on fait ça. On a été
témoin des difficultés des
couples pris sur les bateaux.
Le couple Ménard notamment qui
crie à l'aide.
- Je pense qu'on a une grande
responsabilité au point de vue
de ce qu'on va donner comme
information. Pour augmenter la
capacité de tolérance à
l'incertitude et aussi
pour donner l'impression à la
population que j'ai un sentiment
d'auto efficacité qui est
renforcée. Je me sens capable de
traverser cette épreuve.
Tous ensemble. Ça risque d'être
difficile mais cette épreuve va
être temporaire et je vais être
capable de la traverser.
Pour ce faire, ça va être
important d'avoir accès à de
l'information qui augmente le
sentiment d'auto efficacité.
Claire, précise, qui donne
l'impression qu'on peut avoir
des stratégies concrètes.
Mais aussi des exemples
encourageants. Et donc,
pas seulement sur les
traumatisantes mais aussi sur
les gens qui ont eu la COVID
1900 sont sortis.
- Parle des guérisons aussi.
=- Oui. On voit beaucoup
d'exemples de ce qui est le plus
affligeant dans la nature
humaine. On a parlé aujourd'hui
beaucoup de questions sur les
gens qui vont dans les
épiceries. Mais tous les gens
qui ont décidé de sacrifier
leurs vacances, qui sont dans le
milieu de la psychologie,
de la médecine, les premiers
répondants et les militaires en
consultation. Ça aussi ça va
très important de les voir.
On voit le plus bel aspect de
l'être humain et pas juste..
- l'esprit de solidarité dans le
milieu de la santé.
- Ça risque d'augmenter, de voir
ces exemples, d'augmenter la
solidarité, qui est très liée à
la résilience.
- Vous vouliez dire quelque
chose là-dessus.
- Non je pense qu'effectivement,
enfin, dans tout le règne animal
n'est pas que chez les humains,
la solidarité est plus important
que l'agression. Dans un premier
temps, quand on est agressé
collectivement, on a peur.
Mais dans un second temps, on
s'entraîne procédure comme ça
que ça se passe.
- Les épidémies comme ça, on
peut en sortir gagnant.
On développe des méthodes
qu'on ne connaissait pas avant.
Heureusement cette épidémie se
déroule dans I siècle on a la
technologie qu'on a
ça va nous forcer à changer les
pratiques. Si on est intelligent
dans la façon de faire,
et surtout si on a la solidarité
comme le mentionne les
panélistes,
on risque d'en sortir
plus grand question n'avait pas
une épidémie.
- 10 secondes Docteur Poirier.
Pour la fin.
- On peut prendre des mesures de
santé, de protection.
On n'a pas beaucoup de haute
technologie. Tout ressemble à de
la date distanciation.
- Le message est très clair.
Merci beaucoup Docteur Poirier à
Sherbrooke, merci beaucoup à
vous sur le plateau.
Alors, en terminant,
en raison de la situation
exceptionnelle que nous vivons,
ICI RDI est accessible à tous
deux maintenant même si vous
n'êtes pas abonné.
Vous pourrez suivre tous les
développements de ce qui de
notre antenne. Soyez des nôtres
ce dimanches pour une émission
spéciale Découverte en direct.
Que j'animerai en compagnie de
Charles Tisseyre.
Et d'autres journalistes
spécialistes faire le point sur
la situation du coronavirus au
Canada et sur la recherche de
traitement et de vaccin.
Nos experts répondront à vos
questions toujours très
nombreuses. Rendez-vous de 18
heures 30
RDI la première chaîne. Très
bonne fin de soirée.